we turn our attention now to a
disgusting display that led to charges
being filed against one south jersey man
and brought a community together in
protest a large one in fact it all
started with the video
showing the 45 year old mount laurel
resident in the now viral clip he called
for people to show up
at his home and that is exactly what has
happened action news reporter george
solis live in that neighborhood with
this developing story
george let us know what you're learning
about this
yeah great and sarah this has been a
very active scene here all morning and
afternoon protesters
have been growing by the hour many of
them prepared to stay for the long haul
many of them
compared with signs many of them with
chairs take a look behind me you can see
some of the activity here as they have
staged
outside of this man's home this is
if oh today i got time most people
what it is if today i got time
with a bunch of people this would be it
right there
oh b oh hey get the kids we're going to
camp
where we're going to the mountains no
this [ __ ] in new jersey my
laurel
you mad at it this isn't a problem you
dumb you dumb
damn oh no this is
[Laughter]
remix goddamn and you want to know where
i was when all this happened
i don't care at work i don't care where
you were
at mark just like i told the mount
laurel police
get out of here and you can't do that
word then deciding to save the internet
a lot of time and he just dust himself
to the camera where i live
come see me so you're real comfortable
so get me on video so you know what you
see
bring whoever as it turns out if you say
some horrendous stuff and then say yeah
roll through and you drop your address
dozens of people actually will and by
monday dozens of protesters were
chanting outside of his door that's
because in addition to the video people
in the community claim that he has
passed and launched racist attacks on
several non-white residents for
years this even including a woman who
said that matthew's kicked down her door
and vandalized her vehicle among other
things so by the evening there was over
about a hundred people at one point
matthews briefly emerged
trying to apologize
no no no no
you don't get to apologize if mother
will be like yeah i'm off
pull up and i pull up and you get
outside you say
i just want to say i'm sorry nah be now
i'm here
don't don't apologize square up you
wanted me to pull up
i pulled up and i square up put them
tooth in the air
away from like you just don't care
[Laughter]
you're having fun today
yeah once you find out the haitian
president's dead you're like party
bro bro if you're telling me to pull up
and i pull up and you wait about that
life
yo if if you said pull up and i'm there
i made a decision i made a corporate
decision
that it was happening it was happening i
had to mind myself dress myself
you know get on there motivate myself
put some dmx in the car they don't know
who will it be
know what i mean and then i don't put up
and you're not about this
if i life dmx someone's getting snuffy
do what i mean
you better pray i don't play you better
pray i don't play no
any up i'm gonna tell you to take chains
off take rings off
police even eventually escorted him away
with his hands behind his back as
demonstrators cheered and launched
objects at them also as far as if
anything's gonna happen legally matthews
reportedly was already charged with
unbiased intimidation on friday but also
reportedly after reviewing additional
footage of him the authorities have
added new charges including
finally as far as matthew's right for
his part he has apologized in a
statement to reporters saying
that he was drunk and that his tirade
stemmed from a long-running dispute
involving the homeowner's association
with them also just just brace
just brace for it saying that the slurs
were not meant to be racist
he told you to brace for it he told you
to brace [ __ ]
he did but i was still not ready oh my
god hold up
listen it's the caucasity for me listen
saying that the slurs were not meant to
be racist and that he used the same
language against white people
even he was like hey man i call
everybody numbers
white folks black folks little folks
[ __ ] spicks wet bags
all that matters not racist if i use it
on everybody
[Applause]
[Laughter]
blackout drunk now when i get blackout
drunk you know what the guy don't do
hey man uh women are inferior uh
like i don't know it's just interesting
to me that when people get drunk all of
a sudden this kind of weird language
they supposedly have nowhere in their
heart comes out no no
listen listen listen listen it's cause
it's there somewhere
and you got some sort of soul searching
searching to do
i got some word searching to do but you
got some social security
whatever you got you got to find it
within your soul what it is that
whenever you're drunk
that's come out if ever you're drunk and
you're doing
weird [ __ ] to women is not it no you got
to find it what's
you soul-searching you gotta do
something this man
uh apparently was going after people for
a long period of time
i was constantly starting issues with
folks and then you know some of the
languages used to sound like
yeah i want to call the cops to get you
you know matters out of here
and um when you live in a neighborhood
and you got a hostile
neighbor it's like it's one of the worst
things and when you have somebody who's
as aggressive as he is
you start to fear for your safety you
talk about like i've been getting
weapons
i gotta start thinking differently and
it's like tough to feel comfortable in a
home
where you constantly feel like there's
threats coming if you ever had your
house breaking into it affects you long
afterwards kick your door down
yo kick your door someone comes to your
door says i'm gonna come for you and i'm
gonna get all you guys like
that affects you for a long time period
afterwards sometimes i'm going to call
the cops on you guys and like
it affects you right so there's a
certain cohesiveness to the community
that's broken
when someone's that aggressive you
become very recluse you become defensive
um it has a very like long-term
insidious effect that's a little bit
more subconscious than people realize
um but more so on the
on the surface level maybe you haven't
seen reactions we've met people like
this
oh yeah yeah it happens every once in a
blue moon
oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah that good old
you know
you know yeah you know yeah overt right
yeah yes yes yes yes yes yes the overt
stuff is like
oh wow okay good it's happening all
right cool
cool it's the undercover stuff that's
really weird cause like
what did you say you can't really
pinpoint it you can't really prove it
but this [ __ ] i'm like ah finally the
good old racism i can put my finger on
it
is this it's this right here yeah that
is what it is
he was crazy enough to say it out loud
and be that over
a lot of people are much more subvert
about it
and keep it under wraps so this is one
of those things where it's like
maybe you understand this and it's kind
of [ __ ] up i'm kind of glad when i see
someone being that overt
yes because i'm like it's not in my head
no because you can
everybody can hear it and everybody's
son that's what there's a lot of it you
could put your finger on it exactly you
could be like hey
okay okay we got one
yeah but the other the undercover [ __ ]
you're like what what the [ __ ] you say
nothing but it's there and you feel [ __ ]
i know but i can't [ __ ] are
gonna call me crazy now you're just
overreacting and stuff
and that really hurts when you know that
it's happening
people are telling you know you're
overreacting the overt stuff
that's great that's great i'm not going
to say this though you don't shout out
to black people
some of y'all got time because probably
because it's a pandemic
but see you know on a hunter on a monday
or a tuesday no some of these
[ __ ] took a day off
i could tell that they were like i'm
calling in sick what are you talking
about
they're working from home i'm i'm i'm
camping today you got a wi-fi connection
i could use
okay i'll pay you but get the kids we're
going camping yeah
sightseeing we're going to see uh we're
going to the zoo we're going to see what
kind of animals
rice's yeah and that's for him listen
you know play stupid game win stupid
prizes zero sympathy for me no hope they
throw the book at him
and uh this is what you get that's how i
feel about it you're so
openly dumb about it yeah get what you
get boo yeah win your darwin award
um as far as any other like stuff you
want to mention about this
he didn't mean to be racist fair
oh that's just great he was drunk every
time when he kicked the door down
when he sprayed the can't end up in the
pain when he used
every time every time that's the thing
even
if he's actually not raised
you used that because you knew it was
about to affect someone
so you used it therefore to me
same same even worse amen
if i lived in america she'll get the
strap wrong
straight up get a legal strap listen uh
i know a lot of people say whatever they
want to say
man if it was legal concealed carry hey
hey hey hey get back get back
get back get yours passing that's my
property just pass it
what i'm saying it's just passing sir
sir
not sir
yeah those are my thoughts on this event
what did you guys think about the
response
yeah they came on full force they were
chucking things at him i'm mad at it
yeah
i'm mad at it this fan's an
idiot hey what else would you guys think
in the comments below on camera and he
was filming too
dum da dum dum
[Music]
that keeps
for me